[Música]
Hola Soy Gabriel corchean y les doy la
bienvenida a Expreso de oriente El
magazim quincenal de France 24 en el que
acercamos a América Latina las historias
de medio oriente Esto es lo que veremos
hoy
empezaremos en Turquía porque la campaña
electoral entre en su recta final el
presidente erdogan que se juega su
reelección tuvo que pausar por algunos
días sus actos tras un problema de salud
y su principal oponente político que mal
kiris darlulu anunció pertenecer a La
minoría
del islam lo que provocó un Boom
mediático
Seguiremos en Siria porque el presidente
está regresando en la escena
internacional tras años de aislamiento
analizamos con nuestro invitado las
razones que llevan los países al
normalizar sus relaciones con un
mandatario controversial
y terminaremos en Israel donde se
cumplen 75 años de la creación del
Estado hebreo en medio de fuertes
protestas de la población contra la
reforma judicial del gobierno de
netanyahu hoy Les contamos los orígenes
de este polémico estado
empezamos en Turquía porque las
elecciones generales están a la vuelta
de la esquina el país elegirá entre el
coachingüismo de erdogan o el cambio con
una coalición de seis partidos de
oposición el actual presidente que
Cumple 20 años en el poder tuvo que
pausar por unos días sus actos de
campaña tras sufrir problemas de salud
durante una entrevista en vivo en la
otra orilla su principal rival qué Malú
anunció en un vídeo pertenecer a La
minoría alevi una rama del islam
históricamente castigada lo que causó
conmoción en todo el país vemos por qué
en el siguiente informe
es el hombre que aspira a desbancar a
recepta y erdoan como presidente de
Turquía lo describen como tranquilo y
humilde Pero ha dado de qué hablar en
los últimos días en las redes sociales
que mal cristal rolú habló por primera
vez de su pertenencia a la comunidad
alevi una minoría religiosa en Turquía
víctima de discriminación y a veces de
violencia
soy alevi soy un musulmán sincero creado
en la fe del profeta Mahoma y de Alí
nuestras identidades son Nuestra fuerza
y lo que somos
un comentario que no pasó desapercibido
y recibió más de 100 millones de
visualizaciones en las redes sociales
Chris darlulu nunca había ocultado sus
orígenes alerías pero su decisión de
hablar de ello públicamente rompe un
tabú se ve como un llamado a la
tolerancia esta posición contrasta con
la de receptahib erdoan que se apoya en
los unitas más conservadores el domingo
el presidente acusó a de aprovecharse de
las diferencias étnicas y religiosas del
país nadie te ha preguntado nada sobre
tu secta o tus creencias nadie ha dicho
nada en contra de esas identidades que
reivindicas entonces por qué de repente
sientes la necesidad de presentarte ante
el pueblo con tu identidad sectaria a la
edad de 74 años Los alevines representan
un cuarto de la población turca en un
país mayoritariamente sunita los
alevines a veces son acusados de herejes
incluso de traidores por eso están
acostumbrados a esconder su confesión
pero en este vídeo quieres darlulu Pide
a los jóvenes que le voten en las
próximas elecciones presidenciales para
rechazar toda forma de discriminación y
sobre todo para demostrar que las
minorías pueden llegar a lo más alto del
poder
y en Turquía más de 100 personas fueron
detenidas entre ellas varios periodistas
y políticos en el marco de una operación
antiterrorista en contra del PK el
partido de los trabajadores del
kurdistán el gobierno los acusa de
mantener vínculos con el grupo militante
que considera terrorista pero aún no son
los días de las elecciones generales la
operación fue calificada de intento de
intimidación por la oposición y varias
ongs
está atacando violentamente a la
oposición a todos los actores de la
oposición especialmente a quilish para
recuperar el apoyo de masas que perdió
recientemente o para unir a sus actuales
partidarios contra otros
y vamos hacia Siria
danzando en la escena internacional
después de años de aislamiento por la
guerra civil y la violenta represión que
el jefe de estado impulsó a su población
varios países como túnez o Arabia
Saudita reanudaron sus relaciones
diplomáticas con Damasco que podría
volver a jugar un papel importante en la
región estamos con Justin periodista
hispano cirio Gracias por estar con
nosotros Por qué estos países han
decidido retomar relaciones con vas a
grasa y con qué objetivos
básicamente hay cuatro claves que nos
ayudan a entender esa esa oleada de
normalización de relaciones con el
régimen de bachar las Sad la primera es
que esto estos regímenes lo ven como
ganador de la guerra civil con lo cual
pretenden normalizar la situación con él
y tanto con él como con sus sponsores
hablamos de Rusia e Irán también
la segunda clave es que sobre todo los
países del Golfo Pérsico sobre todo
Arabia saudí
parten de la pretensión de contener el
daño que les pueda hacer
hablamos de dos temas claves Primero
necesitan su colaboración en temas de
seguridad y segunda es más importante
necesitan su colaboración para disminuir
el flujo de drogas que va hacia el golfo
Siria en los últimos años se ha
convertido en un estado narco
uno de los principales proveedores de
diferentes tipos de estupefacientes a la
región Y eso está siendo un problema muy
grande para ir para países como Jordania
o como Arabia saudí entre otros
el tercer punto a señalar en el
comportamiento de estos países es que
hay un claro cambio de paradigma
relaciones internacionales donde países
como los países del Golfo clásicos
aliados de Estados Unidos están teniendo
una época de relaciones muy tensas con
Estados Unidos y con el bloque
occidental y están cambiando
gradualmente hacia un paradigma de
relaciones más acorde con con la visión
China
de
despolitizar las relaciones
internacionales donde se habla con todo
el mundo sobre intereses y donde temas
de fricción política o
o temas relacionados con con derechos
humanos o problemas con el tipo de
ejercer el poder dentro del país no
cuentan de hecho las relaciones entre
Arabia saudí y China están pasando por
un momento muy al alza en los últimos en
las últimas semanas y meses y el cuarto
y último punto es que
la mayor parte de los regímenes árabes
quieren cerrar ya la etapa llamada
Primavera árabe para ellos
Pero qué opina la población Siria de la
normalización de las relaciones con el
presidente a las
Bueno sería muy atrevido por mi parte
decir que sé lo que piensa la población
Siria aparte de que sería falso es un
país de más de 20 millones de habitantes
un país muy fragmentado que vivió una
guerra civil los últimos 10 años por
supuesto la parte de la población civil
de la parte de la población que apoya al
régimen está encantada porque es otro
signo más de que el régimen ganó pero
la mayor parte de la población
y a los datos y a la realidad me remito
entre desplazados refugiados gente que
vive fuera del control del régimen pues
Por supuesto que ven con muchísima
preocupación esos movimientos porque al
fin y al cabo esos movimientos de
normalizar relaciones de manera tan
acelerada con pedirle nada a cambio sin
pedirle ningún tipo de gesto o sin
pedirle ningún tipo de concesión o sin
obligarle a entrar en ningún tipo de
proceso político para pacificar el país
significa básicamente que hay
un grupo de regímenes árabes que decidió
que
todo su sufrimiento durante la última
década pues se borra y ya está es por
eso que ahora mismo existe un
clima de preocupación política muy
importante
vimos manifestaciones dentro de Siria en
las zonas fuera de control del régimen
estamos viendo movimientos entre grupos
opositores que dentro de su debilidad y
su fragmentación entiende
esa última esos últimos movimientos de
normalización de relaciones con el
régimen como algo
vital
y algo de algo de suma importancia al
que hay que hacer frente Muchas gracias
y terminamos en Israel donde por estos
días se cumplen los 75 años de la
creación del Estado judío desde su
nacimiento en 1948 ha sido un país
controvertido no reconocido en un
principio por sus vecinos a la vez libro
con ellos varias guerras tras las que
amplio considerablemente su territorio
rompió así el mandato de Naciones Unidas
que buscaba tener dos estados en esta
zona Israel y Palestina a lo largo de
estas siete décadas las relaciones con
sus vecinos se han normalizado pero el
conflicto con Palestina está más vivo
que nunca en el siguiente informe les
mostramos los orígenes de este estado
hebreo
[Música]
29 de noviembre de 1947 acabada la
Segunda Guerra Mundial la recién creada
organización de las Naciones Unidas
mediante la resolución 181 recomendaba
un plan para resolver el conflicto entre
judíos y Árabes en la región de
Palestina la ONU proponía dividir la
parte occidental de mandato británico en
dos estados uno judío y otro árabe
palestino con un área que incluía a
Jerusalén y Belén bajo control
internacional la propuesta fue rechazada
de inmediato por los Países Árabes de la
zona meses después el 14 de mayo de 1948
tras décadas de intentos propuestas
fallidas y migraciones judías nace el
estado de Israel su artífice y primer
Primer Ministro David bengurion Tan
pronto como se creó el nuevo país sus
vecinos árabes Líbano Siria
transjordania Irak y Egipto le
declararon la guerra Israel venció y
como resultado tomó gran parte del
territorio que la ONU había destinado al
Estado árabe y más de 700.000 personas
nunca podrían volver a sus hogares en
las zonas controladas por Israel
en 1967 estalla la guerra de los seis
días y nuevamente El vencedor es Israel
la consecuencia el estado hebreo ocupa
los altos del golancirios partes del
Líbano y la Península del Sinaí egipcia
finalmente Israel devolvió el Sinaí como
parte de los acuerdos de paz de David de
1978 que incluía el reconocimiento del
Estado judío por parte de Egipto el
primer país árabe en hacerlo los años
siguientes estuvieron marcados por más
violencia y frágiles treguas que rara
vez se cumplían iniciado el siglo XXI
Israel se retira del Líbano pero no
regresa ni los altos del golán ni los
territorios tomados al inconcluso Estado
árabe
en 2017 la administración del entonces
presidente de Estados Unidos Donald
Trump traspasa su embajada de tela viva
Jerusalén Desatando una ola de protestas
y enquistando aún más el conflicto
actualmente el gobierno de ultraderecha
de Benjamín netanyahu ha impulsado los
asentamientos de colonos judíos en las
cisjordania ocupada y ha impuesto
restricciones de movilidad a los
ciudadanos Árabes en esta zona Israel
cumple 75 años pero no todo es
celebración el gobierno está bajo
presión de sus propios habitantes por
una polémica reforma judicial que ha
sacado a las calles a miles de personas
llegamos así al final de esta edición de
expresó de oriente Muchas gracias por
acompañarnos y los invito a seguir toda
la información en nuestra página web
Franz 24.com
[Música]